on revient à présent Lucas sur cette
cérémonie des tops des entreprises qui
se déroulit hier soir à tour les
entreprises modèles d'indr et Loir ont
été récompensé au Palais des Congrès 13
établissements distingués parmi eux la
boulangerie Mons et merveilles qui
remporte le top des tops mais qui a
remporté le Prix de l'Innovation ou
encore du Manager de l'Année face à
l'invité d'honneur gaell le magicien
retour en image sur cette soirée pleine
d'émotion avec Aurélie Renaud etcléo à
Montlouis surloire salué pour son
engagement durable l'entreprise de
transport de 75 salariés fait le choix
de l'électrique elle a investi dans une
station de supercharge et vise 10 % de
ses déplacement en zéro émission d'ici
fin 2024 alors ça peut paraître ridicule
10 % mais l'année dernière on a fait 4
million de kilmè donc ça fait quand même
400000 km à produire en camion
électrique c'est pas rien l'atelier
d'uphard de tour reçoit le top de la
chambre de métier fleuron de
l'artisanadar c'est le spécialiste du
papier peint à la planche l'atelier a
notamment créé du carton pierre une
recette cette ancienne réactualisée pour
travailler sur des décors architecturaux
dans le Castel renaudé le top innovation
revient au groupe Protection Sécurité
Incendie pour la mise au point d'une
plaque de désenfumage ce plastique
devient mou à 80° posé sur une toiture
il s'effondre en cas d'incendie
permettant ainsi le
désenfumage le top de la création
d'entreprise est remis au bibliovor tout
commence par une librairie itinérante
puis une librairie physique installée à
tour en 2020 un réseau est ensuite créé
pour ouvrir d'autres bibliovores en
France aujourd'hui en décembre 2023 nous
sommes 10 bibliovor en France sur C
régions et 13 personnes travaillent pour
le bibliovor pour l'année 2024 quatre
nouvelles librairies sont en cours
d'évolution sur Paris rouand ne et Brive
laagillarde le prix devup revient cette
année au laboratoire érigé notamment
pour ces crèmes de beauté à base de
microencapsulation de chlorophy faut
voir c'est qu'on utilise une molécule
qui est disponible de par le monde où on
a aucune pression sur la nature et cette
molécule là vient d'un process d'up
cycling donc nous sommes en bout de
chaîne le top manager de l'année revient
à Jessica de cou à la tête d'esthétic
Center la plus grosse carrosserie
indépendante de la région centrevde
[Musique]
Loire